I just love acting and and I love the
arts so as a kid I never really thought
I could make a living at it I never
thought of starring and something I just
on a pursuit of learning and getting
better and trying different things and
was so fortunate than to have a level of
success and opportunity to continue to
do it I think for myself you sort of
fall into a category when you have some
success I got into a stage where you're
sort of going to work as an actress like
you want to work but maybe not
challenging myself or you know kind of
being repetitive to some degree and then
getting to a stage recently where I
really got back to the love of wanting
to be challenged and do things that felt
different so I was very fortunate that
Hawks Hall Ridge came to me and that
this this role came to me and that I had
that opportunity I think for so many
actors it's really about opportunity
it's it's about getting the chance to to
do something and it's nice if you're
ready in your life to have the kind of
commitment and preparation to be willing
to do that for whatever the role would
require I find that you have to learn
yourself that there's not one way to do
it
so keep them giving advice to friends
sometimes people are different different
ideas or you know values or preferences
and so I think it's about getting quiet
and seeing what works for you you know
you want to try different things be open
to try things I think
but then listen to yourself like how do
you learn even separative acting some
people learn visually some people learn
so you have to figure out how you learn
and then I would say do that like like
try different things and see what clicks
how do you comprehend it what gives you
permission to feel uninhibited and
connected however that is and I've seen
very you know tremendous performances
and actors who were from very different
places and that's sort of the fun of it
right so I think the real joy of it is
to get comfortable within yourself and
and learn what sort of works for you but
the one thing that I did correctly was I
just tried to get better at it and I
just enjoyed the process so I watched
movies I'd go read things I would take
different types of classes I took improv
as well as you know
acting classes why I just challenged
myself and so I think by growing and the
focus trying to do the best you can to
get better is the best thing you can
ultimately do to give yourself the
confidence and maybe in some way create
opportunities it would not be as
results-driven meaning we all want those
results or those things but sometimes
just doing the best you can kind of is
the right approach to that and being
okay to fail and being okay to take
chances and that's sort of the of
anything in life right get it you put
yourself out of there out there and and
hopefully you know go in to any role in
performance you know really prepared to
make it fun you know go in there or do
what you need to do to make sure that
you're really ready use any fears and
doubts to sort of prepare and then that
is a weird you know balance in that
where you don't want to be so over
prepared that you're burnt out so you
have to find that zone and then at the
best it's collaborative so the fun is is
supporting each other and you know being
there for somebody and making a
difference in those kinds of ways is you
know in theater you have that so often
and in films you do too but realizing
that it's not a singular sport you know
it's it's not a competition it's
ultimately very much so it's a
collaborative medium I mean that's the
joy of it is that you feel supported and
people uniquely understand what you're
going through and so it's very rewarding
I think to to watch other people grow
and get to places and to also get help
getting to places with each other
[Music]
[Music]